white mouth alright what's the premise
of your pipe most white mouth
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh welcome to another
episode of you know the name of I guess
not handsome ramble of podcast I mean
with Tony trim in Melbourne Australia
still with a special guest hearts of
Wrangell the hard booking the toughest
booking of my career my good friend Eric
Andre Eric Andre Thank You Man at this
moment Eric Andre acts like he's never
heard a podcast what how many episodes
are you trying to do is there a order
your order does it just go to iTunes how
does it work
yeah it goes iTunes and SoundCloud I
think maybe Spotify how many of you
trying to put out and I don't know it's
been fun no we're I think we're about
this is the tenth one you do a special
guest ever well something like that like
a special guest every time sometimes
it's just me and Tony but we have we've
had guests recently Oh Judah Friedlander
know Judah Friedlander
we have Franklin as I we had napalm
fremitus coyote how's accents been on a
couple no yeah you're spot-on al Jackson
impression my spot on out actually I'm
about to kill this [ __ ] man stop being a
[ __ ] Tony my favorite DJ presence of my
friends what's your impressions I could
do Obama that's it now look Sasha Malia
Michelle
we need a tax break for the middle class
yeah but he's out Trump's in Trump
nation right away position all right
here's my Trump impression Sasha I'm
Elena I'm unbelievable 70 years old so
we had to cut some stuff out here
because of that this segue won't make
much sense but just roll with it
but enough about dead babies yes we out
here in Australia man yeah first time in
Australia's time yeah third time yeah
I'm wavy look at me yeah bright eyed
I've been taking reduced vitamins I've
been taking really liver detox pills
yeah everything is wavy do you drink
Jameson every night yes I feels like
[ __ ] I feel like I'm fighting a cold oh
yeah do push-ups a job jogged along the
beach along the Gulf
you gotta get a key puncher yeah I could
do that you gotta do a photo file
therapy yeah you ever done cry out there
you know what you seem like you would do
cryotherapy I feel like this is a new
Hannibal I just not seen you so positive
I don't buy it
kazar your adderall no this is the new
you know podcast no but even last night
you were in like I've never seen you
like this
I was like you usually like looking at
the ground staring at your phone you
something I was just bouncing drifting
in and out of consciousness I'm in love
are you yeah I'm fine really
are you gonna pregnant no do you think
about yeah are you gonna get a girl
pregnant eventually I want to get a girl
pregnant over here in Australia and
leave it over here
take it back 5,000 a month PayPal
American back some Australian baby
five g's a month plus the woman's job
that baby gonna be alright nice Peter
son mmm dot okay it's a it's a packet of
upside iron eggs yeah my dogs I don't
know that's what that's what Derrick
Beckles kept saying no no he was
training you wait you doing uh he's
doing dialect training woman Catherine
my saying that [ __ ] in the writers room
and so I'll back it up upside iron eggs
yep pretty good how would you feel about
the show last night man is your first
first did you put the night before no
the warmer [ __ ] no I went to the open
mic at the club to check out though just
check it out check out the vibe how are
your shows out here
damn fine man yes act yeah it's exciting
even with the internet and television
it's exciting to go somewhere super and
at this point Eric Andre
interrupts me and takes up on my podcast
for a few minutes where do you write do
you write on the road or do you come up
with new material mostly when you're in
New York I'm never in New York anymore
I moved from that place where do you
live I live in the side really on the
west side you don't have your PIN and it
ain't know the truth you have your
apartment New York for gigs well what is
um pose them or hardest you ever bombed
in your life was the worst show you read
the worst
[Music]
was the worst audition here room
probably for Tower Heist wasn't great it
wasn't the worst one but I can tell that
the cast is late whoever was running
lines that she was speed reading me yes
yes you thorough she was just kidding me
to her she was not trying it you could
tell what somebody is saying some eye
gives you energy where they trying to
help you
yeah do the best you can but she was
speeding through the lines
it wasn't my worst one but it's my most
memorable one I was your worst was your
worst where's Bom where's Bom yeah uh
it's been a lot man I mean my where's
Bob we've talked about it on here every
West Palm Beach so I was super fun oh
yeah beats is legendary
uh what about the one with the booty
mama it was a booty contest before the
show Oh San Diego State University is a
college so I was headlining who else was
on there James Davis was on that show
remember Byron and so March Ella I think
was on this March I was on it Huff well
it was their homecoming event we get
there
show starting where what cities is in
San Diego San Diego State University and
I was the headliner so it was um excited
to do it
but yeah I found that there was like a
booty-shaking contest before whatever
the show's going people doing right
Marcel the dinner thing James Davis I
think he was hosting fireman goes up
Byron is bombing his bombing no no their
other colleagues had already what did he
do that was I don't know he was just
bombing man and it was and then he went
past his time and he was still bombing
more and he was just bombing or what was
a predominantly black crowd it's mixed
crowd mixed crowd wait then they end up
like taking his shirt off at one point
or something like something like that
was it that I just imagine that possibly
possibly that's not out of the realm of
possibility
so Byron think he did so Byron
struggling he's bummed but then he goes
oh like he's you know he stays out there
stays up there maybe an extra eight
minutes like he's like double downing on
Diamond and I'm going up next and I'm
thinking why is my [ __ ] and he gives
off stays in my a man you can't be doing
that if you bomb and just get out of it
and then I got on stage and I did like a
couple jokes about him bombing like what
about that guy and then did a few
minutes he was going alright then I
started bombing oh yeah
it's the Karma yeah where you just make
it making fun of somebody of a button
embalming heart and just waiting on
state [ __ ] yeah then just the queues
were bad in the crowd that was
distracting the crowd was it like the
attention was alright it was not set up
just been I wouldn't say that I'm sure
other comedians would have handled that
and destroyed it it was just I'm uh I
wasn't right for that situation
yeah maybe earlier in the set I would
have been able to thrive but that was
that was a freedom you do when you
started out to do a lot of black clubs
or like urban night I did some in
Chicago yeah that's what I started out
there I was that it would be cinema
sometimes they'd be like oh this
[ __ ] is okay this is good and
sometimes nothing yeah the same night
same club sometimes same jokes different
crowds you know just sometimes I hit
sometimes it wasn't I remember I would
get they would introduce me in a special
way sometimes I remember doing this one
room and it was a common good comment
put a lot of comedians of Chicago on it
but he you know they introduced me like
you know this next guy you guys you got
to listen to him yeah weird two-button
there you gotta listen your mother [ __ ]
you gotta listen to he's funny
I browser raised already yeah yeah it
was uh it was interesting starting now
man did you do a lot of black room
starting up dead I always would like I
was like I gotta be able to do any in
every room I'll do a room in like the
South a redneck room I'll do like I need
to be able to do any type of crowd um
then i stunk up the joint I be I'm so
bad I would go up to the Bronx and try
to do like urban clubs and some like
that in like Washington Heights yeah and
I would [ __ ] just fall out of my face
every time almost every time sometimes I
could high energy my way into something
and now he's known for pulling his penis
out on stage I didn't know what I was
talking about but I'd be like dude is
crazy yeah I did Wendy Williams Show at
the Laugh actor shed alive comedy show
that Capone yeah he's the host did that
once and I tripped up over my first line
out of my mouth I walk to this stage and
I try to make fun of the girls in the
front row I was I was gonna I said I try
to make some joke like you guys look
like first of all Capone not only was I
trying to do a joke that I flubbed the
line but like Capone already did it
before me but better
oh I said something like you guys look
like I pointed to these three girls I
was like you guys look like if SWV never
made it or something like that yeah but
I was like you guys look like SMP never
made is SWV never made it and then I
wanted to my old hurricane joke it was
like over 10 years ago yeah and I just
looked like it schizophrenic and they
were just like and then I was trying to
like talk about like racial politics of
America right afterwards and I just like
I think I just like sauntered like moon
walked offstage when he was cracking up
though
and then like Capone went onstage after
me and ripped me a new [ __ ] well yeah
for ten minutes that's what I had
minutes
for ten minutes and the crowd was like
standing ovations yeah he's like I don't
know who that was but it'll never be
back that's what I try to do to Byron I
was like no you then you're not supposed
to do that that's not you yeah yeah
didn't work out here yeah born in
Billings Montana and where'd you go from
there no okay oh yeah stop sorry man
so yeah I thought she said this came to
a screeching halt it did man keep this
[ __ ] moving I know you're the black Joe
Rogan no I don't see race you know what
you're the I don't even know you're the
human being Joe Rogan I rap a lot on
this podcast yeah yeah I've been having
getting better thank you
right this way how cuz we had a kid
freestyle rap on the yeah on the stage
last night I jumped up and he spit he
spit bars spit hot flame he'd get into
it right away right off the bat no
hesitation yeah a little bit of that in
the background maybe not the best rapper
of all time but not if he goes in the
pocket but he got in the pocket and he
committed
I admired admired his commitment you
know how many people ask me if I really
click if I really kicked Flavor Flav so
many so many people ask me never asking
me everyday something most ask you so
what would you say yes you committed a
bit outside I say I'm not at liberty to
discuss these things yeah um I I go
I've been legally advised by Hannibal's
counsel yeah that uh
I'm not at liberty to discuss these
matters yeah you know I say also don't
learn final cut or any editing software
don't learn it you tell them that tell
people that you yeah they think is an 8
did you do it no that's assault there's
a song I wouldn't kick somebody in the
face unless it was if I unless I had to
in defense of myself or my family
yeah but for a laugh that's the highest
I've ever seen your leg yeah I didn't
even I didn't even know you had that in
you
do when I went cuz it's been is it was a
year between shooting that in-between it
coming out yeah I hit you of it was that
me like man LA I can't kick like that
that's done double crust it was it was
it was was Flavor Flav actually really
salty about that cuz I saw some tweets
about it very salty maybe he didn't
appreciate that
did he talk to you directly privately no
way he wasn't salty right when it came
out and he was like haha good one gee he
said something like okay okay funny
stuff and then people were like trolling
him like people people like Hannibal
kick whooped your ass
you're a [ __ ] head will kick you in the
[ __ ] face also it didn't help did
media outlets ran it as a member they'd
even put it in quotes or anything he
just like he kicked him in the face and
just ran it straight like that one
clicks one clicks I guess is you know
clicks it was some some say the reason
Donald Trump is president is because
like me people want clicks I think me
yeah and all that all the moments that
should have disqualified him was
basically Free Press well why don't we
start our own clickbait based media
outlet
that's what I mean cook mate that
clickbait okay time to click bait that
click pigweed click bait that click look
at this kangaroo kangaroo kickin it with
a cat and this cat got into politics you
just live it at this party we did not
live edit that part out that wood solid
clickbait stuff I was saying all the bad
parts we just put auto-tune you ever had
to commit to the bit so much man cuz you
know I bail on the show yeah you be
committed in a VA moments where I'm like
committing but in my mind I'm like I'm a
business work you ever think I'm a bad
person I think like yo this sounded
funny on paper but it's coming out of my
mouth meaner than I meant it to be yeah
but we always edit that [ __ ] out
mmm is so much so much so much cutting
room floor oh yeah I don't think any
show has more cutting room before has
there ever been like in an interview
where you had to completely cut like
just completely Gallagher we'd never
really aired past a few frames
he was like impossible to shake because
he didn't listen it was like nothing was
I did for Gallagher yeah I think you
know yeah Oh season two we were there
for all the interviews oh oh you've been
there for every interview well I mean
the first three season you therefore all
interviews and season four you weren't
there just for like Amber Rose and
Raymond cruised they Amber Rose one I
miss and Raymond Roy Hibbert right here
that's the day we had your robot yeah
cuz yes you do don't like daddy
mm-hmm you had to shoot that movie don't
wake daddy don't like daddy's a board
game don't own the daddy
come to Daddy come to Papa come to Papa
so sometimes you oh [ __ ] I'm not sure
that's are you doing something I think I
was doing my
special you're having an identity crisis
I feel like probably that on you were
wearing a different pair of sunglasses
every time I saw you that's you know I
try to you know I try to be luxurious
but still frugal yeah
and so I I do stuff like that you know
we're still do you think do you think
Eric Andre shows the only talk show
where the co-host has a significantly
bigger following and more money than the
host comedy history it's not like Ed
McMahon was like selling out theaters
and then Johnny Carson was like hey I'm
doing punk rock sound what a show
[Laughter]
working on you know my rap career
it's defining it's the defining role for
you yeah Hannibal Burres people get into
the Hannibal Buress co-hosts wrong you
were born as the Roy you're born to play
really the Morpheus yeah the Morpheus
role was known around the streets people
Adult Swim me too yeah what time I was
doing bird up it was the second time I
was doing second year we're doing bird
up I just do it I was like humping some
lady's leg and this guy came up to her
ways like come on you're gonna be all
over Adult Swim letting this guy up your
leg from like a places like fandom yes
just more like WorldStarHipHop adults we
knew I was nothing but trouble
yeah man what I was trying to think of
the bit that got cut also it was when
you make us smoothies while jogging on
the treadmill yeah
to trip oh yeah make smoothies with that
John Kilduff John killed them yeah yeah
that didn't make it I didn't make it
because John Kilduff did the same thing
and it just felt like he did the
authentic version of that and that we're
doing like this like secondhand version
of that it just didn't feel like we're
adding anything that original to what he
already like Yannick Lee created but I
love John Kilduff I just felt bad I felt
back cutting it but um we didn't know
where that was year 1 we had no idea
what we're doing it's pretty well we
didn't have a script so we had like 14
different documents floating around and
nobody ever knew which version was the
most reason for so chaotic GRT did you
already know that you were gonna have
Hannibal yeah Hannibal's been part of it
since the very beginning like me and
Hannibal on kita shot in I was like
abandon Oh dag I'm Brooklyn like 2009
those are nine that seems longer yeah
seems longer ago but it was all night
and it was not the regular one in 11
2011 yeah in the pilot the official
Adult Swim pilot in 2011 season 1 2012
the 2009 is how long ago I remember 7
years 7 years when you first sent the
you sent me like the like the pilot yeah
we're like check this out man and then
like right next and then next it's
really crazy man you were like yeah you
were like oh just came in for like a few
hours yeah I remember I give you a
hundred bucks I think don't tell anybody
give you a hundred bucks cuz I can't pay
anybody else yeah cuz like angry Bob
like other like comedians I think it's
about a bit of more than a hundred if
I'm thinking back right
okay well I do remember yeah nice is
that the pilot yeah that's one minute
bodega that's what you spelled the D WH
ere a IR we were broke back then we
broke his [ __ ] man so broke broke his
food and I remember your whole plan
you're like my whole plan I'm just gonna
ride somebody's coattails you did a
Montreal I think a couple times it was
like what are you gonna do you can't get
into acting you're like [ __ ] I don't
know
that's what happened what I'll go to me
this is what do you want to do it I want
to do stand-up yeah we don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I was going to these big production
companies on general meetings and yeah
what's your story
oh yeah I do stand-up and I like doing
stand-up and I want to do more stand-up
yeah cool well here's your bottle water
office parking not validated for you
I met yet the Botanica bar I thought
Annika yeah Ashville bow ski show I
remember I don't know if you were
hosting a dink Dan curry was probably
instant introduced you to the stage and
then you and him did some kind of crazy
handshake
you know I that's what New York comedy
is about you remember oh my god they did
y'all do some crazy [ __ ] and I was like
oh [ __ ] it's different how do you know
yo I remember asking the bartender if I
could sleep back there cuz I was
homeless and he's like no sleep here I
was like no one will know man he's like
my boss will know he comes in at like
10:00 a.m. I used to sleep at the
Starbucks over 40 seconds
I used to dine out buy coffee and then
not out there then it wake me up oh you
can't sleep here like when your coffee's
not that good yeah those are the days
staying in hostels and [ __ ] spandex was
couch was very helpful yeah
stayed there a couple yo move gave me
yeah God is moving its spin West lad
moving company he was he was from
Chicago so I met him nanny had a moving
company so he hired comedian that did
one the big who's the first him Nate
bargatze and Jordan Carlos were the
three first comedians that I met that I
still somewhat kept in touch with
actually I haven't seen spent years but
like yeah the three that I remember yeah
we were did this was the very first show
I did in New York City and I remember I
told all my friends like I'm doing a New
York City comedy show yeah and it was 6
p.m. it was at this bar in Chinatown
called yellow I found out about it on
the comedy soap box yeah and it was in
this basement of this Chinese bar and it
was like fluorescent lighting it looked
like a detention center and it was like
me and there's no audience there's just
three comedians in the in the audience
know we just all took turns doing
stand-up if we don't yeah and it was
rock bottom whose comedy rock bottom it
was like oh this is a nightmare
I was like and I remember telling my so
I was like if this is what it is at the
beginning this is this as a career is
gonna take ten years yes
cuz I was like 21 I want to say yeah
Eric Andre show I was 28 and I came out
when I was 29 so almost a decade yeah
yeah I started when I was 20 Constanta I
don't think we show enough appreciation
to the people we invited to shows when
we were really horrible at Stan yeah
want to take a shout out give it put
some put some smooth music under this
just some smooth reflective music to
anybody I invited to show between the
years of 2002 well you went to school
boss I went to school in Boston I
started in Boston that I remember what I
thought was like funny it was like not
funny yeah like I had a joke where I
want to I walked about stage why did I
say I was like I think it was like so
anyway we're all gonna die soon I don't
know some it was like something like so
anyway I hate myself and I thought it
was like so funny I was like yeah like
oh people are gonna think I'm crazy I
[Laughter]
don't know if I have one of your old
ones and it was like an acronym Sarah
yeah Sarah stupid as [ __ ] as how
yeah that was killing when I was 19 you
know Sarah stupid as [ __ ] as Oh
has a balance I had one I had one that
was like um it was so like obvious and
hack it was like I hate when people say
when you're about to go on an airplane
and they say have a nice flight it's
like what are they gonna say have a
crazy flight and then I did this whole
crazy act out like news go on the plane
and have a [ __ ] put a knife in your
dick I look back filmed it I remember
looking back on that a few years later I
was like that is like the most boring
like obvious premise you know sometimes
stuff is more of a video scare is not
fun I have video of my year 1 I have
like a video I had edited of me doing
stand-up at like three or four different
comedy clubs in Boston year one I
haven't watched it in probably 10 years
and I should dig it up it's in my mom's
garage on DVD yeah that's like me at
like comedy connection it's all Boston
Club so it's like Remington's which is
dick dougherty's Victor Ortiz dicks
Nick's comedy stop comedy connection and
some other [ __ ] spot and I'm sure
it's [ __ ] embarrassing
yeah yeah the first real shows were the
shows where your friends didn't come
because the first like four shows I
think I did I invited all my friends
then the fifth show was at the comedy
studio across the street from Harvard
and that was the first time I ever
bumped I was like oh and I went like I
went like panic attack mode where like I
look like was out of body on stage
everything got bright mouth get dry
super dry mouth swallowing swallowing
uncontrollably sweaty
these heat on spaghetti there's vomit on
his sweater spaghetti monster spider
flight response yeah and I remember that
feeling and like that feeling like
lasted like the first like three years
of doing comedy it wasn't til and I had
a panic that seems like the moat like
for me seems like the most frightening
thing ever is to bomb a comedy like just
you can hear people makes you stronger
yeah but like you just gotta learn how
to that's how you learn you actually
learn more from bombing than you do from
having it's at least in the beginning
you learn how to embrace the silence and
feel comfortable onstage when a joke
doesn't go your way and that's what
makes you a comfortable confident
comedian and you know you start having
control do it but it's hard yeah you
ever bring a girl to a show and then
bomb and then she says I don't want any
parts of it oh yes well you know what
not so directly but I definitely
definitely brought a girl or torte
already was dating her but she hadn't
seen me do stand-up yeah yeah and
actually happened recently and brought
her to a show and just tag and that had
nothing to it wasn't like the comics
before me tank like the comics before me
did well and I got on stage and just
stank up the joint it is the worst
feeling it's um it's like magnified
times yeah when you bring a girl that
you like or go you're dating it's like
ooh that sucks or bobbing in front of
your parents or a family member yeah
especially when you're starting out like
now I have a TV show so if I bomb in
front of my dad it's like whatever
whatever I got it
back in the day bombing in front my mom
or my dad it was like bad I was like oh
oh oh not enough commitment to materials
not a good that Eric can I suggest a tag
for your daughter
you sound like was that do them well no
no let me take it to the movie tickets
and Amir bangs bangs bangs ship boy bang
yeah I when I was at Saturday Night Live
I sent that video to Andy Samberg yes
and he used some of the ad-libs as
inspiration for his shy Ronnie character
really with you in the first shot Ronnie
video with Rihanna where he go haha
that's from bangs man okay also I wrote
a line there Rihanna said in that song
when I was just when I was in a movie
with both of them yeah called pop star
theaters everywhere yeah you're a Navajo
I heard it was great it was great it
didn't do well at the box office but it
was good what do you think afternoon um
maybe aren't marketing I was trying to
figure it out I think that nobody knew
what it was from the poster that's a big
deal yeah because it was like and II was
like silhouette in the poster and the
name of the thing was pop star I think
people thought it was an authentic
Justin Bieber kind of documentary and
they didn't know as a goof I think if
you saw his face it wasn't a silhouette
image if you saw his face and I had
maybe like a goofy or title yeah that'd
be 100 it's a comedy he's making fun of
that [ __ ] but I don't think like people
understood maybe I also just think the
movie industry is falling apart and
we're selling and dated with media that
way
nobody knows where to begin and you know
what is gonna make somebody leave their
house my cameos in neighbours daddy's
always secret lover past Angry Birds and
nice guys it's like when a movie comes
out you go I can wait a few weeks just
turn on my Apple TV and download it
what's what's the what's making you
leave your house to go see the movies if
it's a comic book movie because you want
to see surround sound like crazy you
want to see you on the big screen like a
new Star Wars you know what I mean it
has to be something like that and that's
funny huh for me what makes me yeah well
my cameos and neighbors daddy's home
secret lover past angry birds and nice
guys so you have a knack for being and
really critically acclaimed under
marketing projects let's talk about man
seeking woman sure what the [ __ ] could I
do it over there
they don't market it tell me take that X
off of that [ __ ] I have no idea why FX X
exists that's the X operator on FX
you don't need no FX X that sense of
[ __ ] it already happened
yeah so that's X FX and give us a
billboard something people know that
shows great man oh it's on FX X you saw
x-axis people don't even know how to
find yeah it's like a billboard they
don't give us any marketing the show is
so weird man I think I started watching
it on the road I downloaded on iTunes
and I just started watching what the
foot is great oh yeah
címon rich Jay Baer said great so bad
you so surreal it just gets so weird man
yeah oh man
FXX the [ __ ] y'all doing over there
what's the dude's name that runs FX
louis ck's best friend Rupert Murdoch
Rupert no it's led together who is it
who is it
let grasslands banks Landgraf is it
Landgraf
not execs leg grab get me in trouble mr.
Landgraf I seek a woman the opinions of
Hannibal Buress I did what I did and
then I did swirly eyes and then yeah man
perky stared I danced warily at I'm a
fan duh
damn you started going to therapy what's
that mean first ten years knowing you
you were like Rain Man you just stare at
your phone what that's all you would
deep undercover not think I'm just your
show host I'm in taken I've been taking
these boost vitamins
shoutout to boost vitamin so your
family's very grounded in normal yeah
what do you think I am well you're like
it's like yeah it's you're like Robert
De Niro in awakenings really in the
corner there first ten years yeah but
something something happen you took some
flowers for algernon type of pills and
now you're yeah you were like you
respect to me you kind of just be
introspective Chile yeah oh yeah you
were that guy yeah yeah iceberg or
something like you could probably read
five books in a day and I haven't
memorized but then it's like Hannibal
you want to do later huh
just rock back and forth it's a it's a
compliment I feel like you're doing
great my ex-girlfriend said the same
thing recently you know I think you
conquered your heart said I like the
Asperger's part of you a second baby
your eyes are all [ __ ] up she can if
she just threw it away so no I think she
said it in text he's like oh yeah
your ass burgers like what the [ __ ] my
husband maybe I am no I do get hung up
on just little things weird little
triggers weird little detail yeah and in
triggers any of my your minefield and
energies you dig you would get mad at
one woman a year on the show I noticed
there was always one guest and it was
always a female guest and you would add
at all 20 guests there would always be
the 19 we'd call him the 19th guest your
one--is brandi glanville your two is
downtown Julie brown year 3 I used to
know was great for it was the but most
of them off here 3 it was jillian
Barberie year four was Abby Lee Miller
but they all said foul [ __ ] yeah I mean
we're saying foul [ __ ] that'd be like
it's all fair in love and war I'll try
to think what there's something that
triggers you I think when a white woman
says a specific thing I don't know I
don't know what it is well the one maybe
you were picked on a white woman when
you were little no stick ingesting well
the what the latest one was it was a
Dance Moms that really annoy Abby Lee
she started talking about my mom yeah
who's rude yeah and that sector yeah
you can't talk like joke about me yeah
jillian Barberie said some racist [ __ ]
yeah what about downtown Julie brown now
downtown Julie brown
she seems he seemed the most passive and
long I forget what it was with downtown
Julie brown I don't remember it probably
wasn't but in a good 19 out of 20 guests
the year you're great and they're saying
wife crazy foul [ __ ] there's no rhyme or
reason to it and then brandi glanville
i don't remember us she'd - she called
you creepy oh yeah yeah I wasn't used to
my character yet Julie brown though just
kept like putting her Fedora on you or
something I don't know and you were like
[ __ ] her yeah yeah I'm an unreasonable
man
a few weeks ago I argue with somebody
normally why did I even start arguing
with them
that was this really still visit Jameson
sometimes - James yeah I'll tell you
this when I drink whiskey even when I'm
not even when I'm hungover the next day
or like not when I'm not even when I'm
drunk off whiskey like the next day or
the day after I'm like really like
temperamental yeah curmudgeon yeah and
like easily so what I need to start
drinking
jim-jim anything else vodka vodka mm
anything else I've been [ __ ] with
wine a lot lately wine yeah some nice
fine Shiraz is the surest just try to
cut it out and just be be free no but
this is all to say this is the best I've
ever seen
you seem very healthy you seemed full of
life and positive you know what it might
we recorded ads earlier and I killed
that [ __ ] yeah I was singing yeah but
even last night you seemed like on a
high I feel like there's a whole new
Hannibal I mean I gotta think what it is
I've been Australia trip has been good
man bang Boing yeah your girlfriend's
coming to your show
she is she's gonna catch the last one
yeah she's she's landing in like 6 a.m.
wait how many more show you got one
tonight and another one tomorrow I might
be wrong yeah
- tonight maybe just one tonight Wow did
you add wanna see no I got two tonight I
got one tomorrow in Sydney then two on
Saturday where it goes one two one two
Sydney Sydney Melbourne yeah yeah you
want to talk about your girlfriend
that's too deep man you think people
because we will cut this I'll cut this
is just us talking
I'll play I'll sing it from the hilltop
famous girlfriend yeah yeah you know
what is on Medea from the toy everybody
knows man you know what I respect your
privacy dog you know what I don't care
yeah I don't care I'll say she just
watched out of things she doesn't care
she just has dated famous people before
and she's like it puts a it puts a
pressure on the relationship once it's
out but is it puts a little bit of a
magnifying glass a little bit a little
bit I mean we're not the Kardashians but
but it's all y'all already put a
magnifying glass on it I'm telling
picture of us just having a good time on
social media weren't kissing in the
picture I think it's three and this is
Maynard and they're not kissing okay
that's true hanging out on Instagram man
you know what no Liv gets live gives
live gives some space for a clean cut so
you really haven't tried cry out there
[Laughter]
you haven't I tried it it's uh you know
what it is it's like the freeze you you
think you where you go in for ninety
seconds to a couple minutes
it's just basically a concentrated
version of you know athletes go into the
ice bath to recover and have their
bodies recover fast is that so you go in
really good dirt it's only two years
miserable but you've how thrill you got
some music going how long are you in
there I think is in a minute and a half
to three minutes floatation therapy we
lay and you can kind of get suspended
all the isolation can you uh your body
gets relaxed for y'all ISM and
floatation theories where you lay in a
saltwater tank
well saltwater pool which is a sensory
deprivation that's a deprivation that's
what all its pure black and then they
can't see your hand in front your face
totally silent soundproof booth your na
98.6 degrees saltwater tub and you're
floating so you're not touching anything
you know see anything you don't hear
anything and it is deeply deeply
meditative and relaxing yeah but I
haven't done the cryofreeze my dude
what's the longest you did cuz I heard
you start tripping balls after all I
wasn't like that it was this more chill
I was in there for half an hour I
started seeing stuff yeah yeah you
started seeing weird stuff oh you went
in yeah everything when you were growing
up this in the end the shy the side that
you would experience this much of the
world as the world opened your eyes I
every time I travel I feel like I grow a
little bit I I think it's something to
travel especially being over here where
you don't see many people that you know
yeah it is something about you know not
being familiar and just having it just
your mind saying stuff and it puts you
in a different I like I didn't know
exactly what I wanted to do a boner
while shooting City yeah yeah yeah or
sometimes we tell that he forgets
surprise you with your dad first time he
came out during the kick
you killed it actual foreign act I ran
into him at the I saw bbw porn with him
yeah four-way
I sent you know a biggest girl you broke
that one oh you know I asked wait ain't
no scales at the W Hotel oh yes three
hundred well yeah I've messed around
with some pretty girls yeah under 300
though I'm thinking under 300 yeah how
about you Eric I probably gotten up to
200 yeah 200 club we all in the 200 Club
listen Tony I don't think it's
respectful to call it a club like that I
don't think these women who have shared
the night and my bed with me would
appreciate me refer to like that you
ever had a girl take a snapshot of you
while you're going down on them no but I
have heard a girl
that this out I talked about this this
is it's just is because I make some bad
decisions I don't know that bad
decisions but it's you know out of just
trying to keep the night going and being
a chaser of energy and stimuli I will
you know do a lot of things I would
normally do if I was at home with my bed
being closed so in Phoenix my bed being
closed so the day before Thanksgiving
for sound please the day before
Thanksgiving I uh
we had show my sister lives in Phoenix
now so uh I do holidays down there so I
booked the gig day before Thanksgiving
do the show at stand-up live we have a
home when we take triki triki triki t
tricky t set up an after-party for us at
this place tricky T's not telling you
know we go back I'm Ricky T so he says a
better
ruff-ruff
Lulu we set up the after parties a day
or so before and so they'll be we'd like
the Milwaukee one you know what that was
a date it was fun whatever playing music
Wilin out some weirdos oh dude this guy
kept trying to touch my dick every time
I find
a little bit like dude it's a part if
you do it once right if you do it like
15 times it's like that's weird too
because there's some weirdos acog who
were like yeah you're Milwaukee dude
it's like all the weirdos get kicked out
of Chicago I mean you just counted
across you have to bear it man you get I
was there every when I got the Chicago
every Chicago in I talked to it's like
yeah you don't want to go Milwaukee [ __ ]
about it and I said sis Carson I've been
in Milwaukee but I said a vacation place
constant payment I've been walking watch
nobody ever tried to touch my dick you
not playing schizophrenic must want his
dick touch always yeah yeah I can't
forget that I don't crazy I am on the
show because I'm not really that easy in
real life and then like people are so
nuts to me if there's I'm like oh yeah
I'm like crazy I Derek that I'm kind of
in like a heightened state when I'm
performing yeah that story that you told
me cuz I met you on the road that's the
first night where you went right please
talk yeah yeah
so Vancouver the first show of the tour
this year is Vancouver yeah the crowd
was so nuts and they were handing out
glass bottles at the bar which I [ __ ]
scolded them for a jump out in the crowd
it's you know crowd-surf the kids pull
down my pants this one kids stuck all
four fingers in my ass okay grab my dick
as hard as he could it's all
simultaneous grab my dick as hard as you
could
other kid give me a wet willy and his
other kid picked a hot dog off the
ground and shoved it into my mouth and I
like gang-raped you saw the audience and
like drawn and quartered they were like
told me all different ways that I was
like never stays ever you had a bowtie
out to and yeah joking me I couldn't
breathe I was like dude I cannot breathe
like straight up like not as a joke I
can't like man cutting Osby story
like I was laughing but you were talking
about it like doing this dramatic it was
a couple times they always grab my boat
I think was the only thing those
slippery so the only thing again but it
was a few times and I had to like I did
like a tornado
yeah and then you like some Undertaker
like I don't know how to fight wrestling
[Laughter]
Ultimate Warrior punch oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah in Portland I almost got thrown off
of they had the downstairs to the
basement bar the staircase is in the
middle of the pit like the venue
everybody stands mmm
crowd cheering and I almost got tossed
off into like the basements Terrica I
would have felt like a story yeah broken
a rib or broke my right and I was like
kicking people in the fans like no no
don't throw me to the thing and the more
I struggle in crazy the more people
laugh they're like uh he's doing a bit
I'm like I'm not doing a bit like I'm
gonna die and I look at the people along
the perimeter of the staircase and I was
like no and they like helped me like get
away from it last second oh my god yes
so crazy yeah I do you ever get injured
have you gotten injured
the one time I jumped off stage in
Nashville this is like the first season
one tour I jumped off stage in Nashville
and this kid whoa whoa and my naked eye
ball like went right I broke my fall my
eyeball ah and then I landed on the
floor and I was like aha and then he
kicked me in the crotch as hard as he
could and I was like oh I kicked him in
the stomach as hard as I could
Oh like right his stomach yeah I keep my
digging yeah
[Laughter]
whenever you start doing it crazy [ __ ]
and running in a crowd always step back
bring all the people on stage all the
way back yeah now start you know I
remember what I first started doing that
you were like oh this is intense when I
was like my next guest is everybody on a
break everybody on stage yeah at first
you're like oh this is cool you're like
trying to pull chicks numbers it was a
you know you'd be like shows are
different kind of vibe but yeah then
telling jokes stating witty observations
yeah that was very impressive man it's
fun the fun the Chicago show I think
that was one of the best cuz I went up
in the balcony and everybody's in the
back answer safe but I was wrecking be
with this these people had like bottle
service you know it's not only a hall
right yeah so they're people in the
balcony with a little bottle service I
took this ice bucket Joan Cusack's he's
had though that was such a that was such
a good yeah that was yeah I was a fan
and that's the one where I came out as
Mila for Morpheus remember yes yes I was
wrong
but my body can't I don't think I could
do that yes I think I would do a fifth
season of the show but like I don't
think I could do a sixth I would do a
fifth season I would do a fifth tour and
then buy that at a time that's happening
I'll be 35 years old and I don't think I
can take like pokes to the naked eye
ball yes that much anymore what about
the show in general you just you know I
think well you know the problem that
shows that it's prank based so the
secrets kind of out now sounds like it's
gonna be hard to find celebrities that
like can just search you know people can
just google search anything now and
people like recognize me so much more I
recognize this guy's so much more like
exponentially I feel like this year
turned the corner to there's a definite
jump between season 3 and season 4
at least for me my name y'all did the
corner firm and a lot yeah a lot of that
stuff you did leading in you know I
think the RNC cuz I was like why I was
like these kind of pranks for years I
wonder what the RNC I think the RNC made
it feel very real I'm here we're like oh
this dude this isn't scripted this guy's
really going into dangerous yeah
positions in that tender video that's it
no that's it baby up for real help like
that super video and I did the hot wings
challenge yeah complex and those things
like it's in the video when I want so
many of those you don't think they're
gonna do anything but both of those are
people I use your pickup lines on tinder
I got laid because of the lines you guys
were coming up with like oh my guts
awesome it's [ __ ] yeah I passed the
torch unto you girls always think I'm a
catfish and on tinder I've seen I've
seen girls profile things like I'm just
on here to meet Hannibal Buress or I'm
just on here to meet ya yeah yeah
they think I'm catfishing it and then I
don't like give them when you show up
what happens end up meeting up with them
if that's what they like
of course it's not you and I guess me oh
prove it cuz I don't want to get
murdered and then I've lately I started
saying you know I could still murder
me being me doesn't exclude me it's like
it's just you confirmed and you had a
phone but anybody can murder you just
because it's so it was yeah we usually
don't meet up once I say that yeah they
don't like hard realism logic
yeah but they it kind of sours the mood
it makes the move weird I just [ __ ] so
bad you put in the emoji emoji be ready
then I'll be ready didn't really need
you guys doing that I need to be two
separate text really my self texting
why don't have separate those although
very short synthesis we need to hey
everybody
we need the text efficiently so what is
this I mean you added her on there what
you just showed that's between me and
Tom that's between you and Tony and
access access theater Eric Andre's
Instagram then that's that man I deejay
for your girlfriend before really yeah
in Phoenix yeah out of Phoenix man I did
it before she didn't hire she was there
having to be there and the owner was
coming up to me like we have a very
special guest in the house and they
would like you to play I think those
shooting some noise was some award of it
AJ was there AJ Calloway it has to do
they used to be on 106 & Park and so uh
at one point did I say that or did you
suggest this will lose wheezes it played
zippers rap over don't you suggested and
I didn't even know this is a joke I told
he's played zippers rap over and over
again to see how happy
in my socks got all my things degrees so
he plays it one time and I'm looking at
the group but they kind of I see a fake
kind of vibe into it and then they play
it again and then it plays again and
then this is looking like what the [ __ ]
yeah well I didn't know it was your
girlfriend at the time cuz well he said
it was someone important but they were
like in a booth we just started dating
so sure well I'm just saying like I
didn't know it was her oh woman that
we're talking of but if I did it's
mystical woman is only an Instagram but
if I had if I would know guys sure I'll
play whatever the [ __ ] she wants to hear
yeah you know and then yeah I it's
pretty odd Nick Oh paragon J is farting
on the balcony fish capisce yes sir that
was that yeah I really do have to ship
well on that note yeah thanks man
totally good it was great we saw what
are you guys doing
[Music]